Welcome to Emerging Approaches
to Evaluating Learning.
My name is Evan Sanders.
I am the associate director
of curriculum services
for teaching and
learning technologies
at Harvard Medical School.
And with me is--
Josh Bookin.
I'm the associate director--
assistant director-- I just
gave myself a promotion.
Yeah.
The assistant director
of instructional support
and development at the Teaching
and Learning Lab at HGSE.
So we're really excited
to have this hour
to think about how
evaluating learning
is really a critical part
of the feedback loop,
during a day where
we're mostly talking
about evaluating teaching.
But of course, when we think
about the efficacy of what
we're doing, we have
to keep evaluating
learning very much in mind.
And so when Josh and
I thought about how
we were going to
approach this session,
we were thinking about,
well, what really
qualifies as an
emerging approach?
What's sort of inventive
in this context?
Is it high technology?
Is it big data?
Is it novel pedagogy?
And so, of course, it
can be all of the above.
But rather than have
us stand up here and do
some boring literature review
about all of those things,
we thought the
best approach would
be to highlight a couple
people who are here
at the University, who
are really wrestling
with a lot of the things that
you were just reflecting upon
on that intro polling slide.
So with that, I think it
would be good to actually
just reflect a bit together
on what some of those things
were that you said.
Can we see that?
We cannot.
I think it'll pop up.
There.
OK.
It would be pretty
hard to summarize this,
or to pick specific
themes, but I
think general themes
that you can see just
by glancing at this
quickly is that these are
higher-order considerations.
These are things that we
want to assess about efficacy
of teaching and learning
that are definitely
hard to do with what
we might consider
to be classical
methods of assessment.
And so that's precisely
why we're here today.
So we didn't want to spend
much time on the intro,
so we could get into
the case studies, which
we have found individually very
rich and thought provoking,
and we hope you will as well.
But we did want to do
two things in this intro.
And one was to think a little
bit about the landscape
of evaluating learning.
And the other one is to
give a bit of a framework
with an idea of, we have
these specific cases
and we want to be
able to abstract
some general principles
that can be applicable
to our own context and
to our own practice.
And so that's what we're going
to hope to do in short order.
And so first we wanted to
start with terminology.
And the idea of
evaluation, we were
trying to figure out, how does
that translate into assessment?
And so for us, we're
thinking about it
in the session of
evaluating learning
as similar or synonymous
to summative assessments.
And a common definition
of summative assessment
is evaluating student
learning at the end
of some instructional unit.
And so we feel like that's a
good, bite-sizable chunk for us
to think about here
in our hour together.
We're not, thus,
going to be talking
about formative
assessment, also very
important-- ongoing
understanding and checks
for understanding of
what your students know
and are able to do.
So with this idea of thinking
about summative assessment,
understanding by
design is a framework
that we felt as we
talked about these cases,
and I in my own experience
as an instructor,
an instructional coach, have
found to be foundational in how
I think about designing
and how people
think about designing units of
study, whole courses, or even
entire programs.
And so understanding by
design is a simple framework,
but it's not simplistic.
And it has three main steps.
And so the idea is,
you start at the end.
It's backwards planning of,
identify your desired results,
then move to determining
what's the acceptable evidence,
and then, only then,
going to the idea of,
what are the learning
experiences that I'm
going to engage my learners in?
And for the focus of
our time together, we're
going to be on the second
step of determining
acceptable evidence.
And in doing this, in
thinking like an assessor,
there's some
foundational questions
that we all need to consider.
And so we're going to
throw them out there.
And I invite you to think about
them throughout these case
studies, and think about how
these three steps and the three
questions I'm about
to do have informed
what these two different
groups of folks
have thought through, as they've
tried to figure out something
that can really
fit their context
and their student needs.
So in terms of thinking
like an assessor,
one is, what kind
of evidence do we
need to actually see that our
goals are being accomplished?
A second is, what
specific characteristics
in student responses,
products, and performances
should we examine?
So this one stood out
to me as the idea of,
it's not just-- if we
have rich assessments,
there's a lot of data
that is being produced.
And we need to think about
what parts of that picture
are important for us to be
able to take stock of it
and be able to evaluate
it against some criteria.
And then the third
one we can drill down
to the individual students
producing this data
and think about, does
this proposed evidence
enable us to infer the
knowledge, the skill,
or understanding
that we're hoping
to instantiate in our students?
So with these questions
sort of taking forward
as a light framework
into the case studies,
the one other thing we wanted
to accomplish in the intro
was some typologies
of emerging approaches
to evaluating learning.
So there's a lot
of different ways
in which we can and
do evaluate learning.
And what we tried
to sample from here
were things in the
higher ed context
that are gaining
importance and that
are in line with research-based
best practices of what we know
from the learning sciences.
And so the first one that
I wanted to highlight
was portfolio-based assessment.
And the idea is not
just a single artifact,
but compiling a set of artifacts
from a given student or group
of students.
And often, it allows us to get
a more holistic picture of what
that student knows, and you can
see a progression over time.
And this type of assessment
started, primarily, in the arts
and in design schools, but
it's used much more widespread
in a variety of disciplines,
especially with the advent
of electronic portfolios
or e-portfolios
where it's a lot easier
to compile student work.
A second emerging approach
that is gaining significance
is competency-based assessment.
And this idea is about
mastery and divorcing mastery
from sort of seat
time, if you will.
And for those of you familiar
with Boy Scout merit badges,
that's sort of an original type
of competency-based assessment.
If I'm doing knot
tying, it's not
that I have to go
through an entire course.
Whenever I think that I am
proficient in tying knots,
I can go for an evaluation
and get my badge.
And there are similar types of
things like that in higher ed,
especially with online courses.
You can go through the
material at your own pace
or even skip over the material,
and see whether or not
you actually have mastery.
The third of the four
that I'm going to touch on
is peer- and self-assessment.
And the idea-- this has
been growing in uptake
in higher education for at
least two significant reasons.
One, the learning sciences
is showing how important
metacognition is, having
students know what they know
and know what they
don't know, and be
able to build those skills
in them as lifelong learners,
with the rapid rate of change
and learning that they'll
need to do as professionals.
And the second is the
growth of group work
and being able to,
as an instructor,
disaggregate all these
different folks who came
together and created a product.
You know, who-- we still
have individual grades--
who was responsible for
what part of the experience?
And then the last one
I want to talk about
is performance assessment.
It's also known as
authentic assessment.
And this is the idea of having
some problem-based task that's
usually approximating
a real-world skill.
And in this type
of setting, when
we looked over the
Harvard landscape
about case studies we
wanted to highlight,
we saw a wide variety of
performance assessments being
used.
And so actually, both
of our case studies
focus on performance
assessments.
And we think it's
particularly important here,
as we look at the types
of students we have
and our goals in higher ed
as undergrad and graduate
education, to be able,
not just to get people
to know and understand
things, but to use it
flexibly and creatively
out in the world.
And so our idea with
performance assessment
is with two different stories,
different contexts, and really
interesting adventures
about how they've
gotten to where
they've gotten to,
we can learn some things
that we can take away
for our own practice.
So with that, I
will hand it over.
My name's Teddy Svoronos.
I'm a lecturer of public
policy at the Kennedy
School of Government,
where I teach
statistics and econometrics
and the core curriculum
to our Masters students.
So the people I teach are not
going to become statisticians,
as much as I'd like
them to, but instead,
are going to hopefully use
the tools of data analysis
in their sort of policy
careers down the road.
This is some work that I did
with Mae Klinger, who is not
currently here, and
Dan Levy, who is here,
on the use of two-stage
exams in a classroom setting
for this quantitative course.
Those of you that don't
teach quantitative courses,
I think that
there's still plenty
here, so please
don't write me off
just because I said
I do statistics.
But hopefully there's
plenty that, I think,
can lead to some
interesting discussions.
I'm going to start
with the punch line,
so if you want to be
surprised, eyes closed,
ears closed, for like
the next 30 seconds.
This started as an effort
to promote learning,
not evaluate learning.
And in the process, we
came across a metric
to use that actually helps
us understand the ability
of our students to collaborate.
So in the process of looking
for a way to promote learning,
we came across the
way to evaluate it.
And in the process, this has led
me to question my own teaching
methods, and to
evaluate my own teaching
and understand the extent
to which I can improve it
over time.
So before I get into
the nitty gritty,
I want to thank the
inspiration for this--
Eric Mazur and Carl Wieman
are in the physics departments
of Harvard and Stanford, and are
kind of the originators of this
two-stage exam concept that
I'll explain in a second--
funding from V Pell,
excellent research assistants,
and excellent colleagues
at the Kennedy School
that provided some guidance.
So I'm going to start by
explaining why I think
two-stage exams are important.
Then I'm going to talk
about how they work.
I'm going to give you
a sense of the data
that we have, and
sort of the process we
did of analyzing the data, and
then what I think this implies.
So first, why two-stage
exams even matter.
The thing that has
always bothered me
is, if you think about a
student's experience in most
classrooms, they work
with the course material
throughout the semester in
class, out of class, together.
They spend a bunch of time
studying for the exam.
They take the exam and
then they get their grades.
Hopefully this is a
non-controversial sequence.
The thing that frustrated me
is that if I thought about when
students were
actually learning, it
felt like it happened
throughout the semester,
it happened while
they were studying,
but then the exam was
basically just an assessment.
The exam was, can
you do the things
that you've been
studying for or not?
And then we posted solutions,
and very few students
look at them.
How few?
Very few-- 38% in
a midterm exam.
We tracked how many
people actually
looked at the solutions,
downloaded them.
38% for a midterm, in which
how well you did matters
for the final because
it's cumulative-- still,
less than half of people
even looked at it.
So part of this was
to try to figure out
how we could bring learning
into these other two
parts of the process.
And that's what
two-stage exams do so.
The idea is that a
standard exam, let's say,
is three hours long,
from 9:00 to noon.
It's an individual exam.
You take it, that's it.
In a two-stage exam,
we instead divide it
into a two-hour individual
exam, and then we
add an additional
hour of group work.
And when I say
group work, I mean
we take the questions
from the individual exam,
we take the most challenging
or complex ones that we think
could benefit from
group interaction,
and then the students redo
a subset of those questions
together in this
group of four or five.
And we structure it so that
it can only help their grade,
it can't hurt their grade,
so people don't freak out.
But essentially
what we're doing is
trying to force
students, when they
hand in their first-stage exam,
don't just walk out of the room
and never think
about this again.
Instead, engage with your peers,
talk through what's happening,
and see what you
can get from it.
So in the process, we hope
that using two-stage exams
integrates active learning
into the exam setting.
It forces people to
instruct one another.
It forces people to be critical
about how they're thinking.
It forces them to engage
with the material,
even after the initial
assessment, which hopefully
leads to longer-term
gains, and it
develops skills of debate
and collaboration related
to course topics.
There's maybe a
specific set of skills
related to working in a group
on a quantitative question that
isn't captured in a
single-stage exam.
So what that looks
like is, the stage 1
looks like kind
of a normal exam--
sorry for the lighting--
and the second
stage is this kind
of cacophonous group of people
working in little groups,
talking through different
questions and issues they had,
dividing up work sometimes,
and really working together
to submit a second
stage that represents
their sort of
collective knowledge.
There are some
groans and sadness
in the room when people realize
that they did a question wrong,
but that's part of--
it's sort of by design.
It's a feature, not a bug.
So generally, people
seem to like it.
84% of the learners that
we've done this with
reported that a
two-stage exam was
more helpful for their learning
than a traditional exam.
But now I hear people
grumbling under their breath
that this is not a measure
of actual learning.
I didn't actually hear
you guys grumbling, but--
this is not a
measure of learning,
this is a self-report,
a self-assessment,
of whether or not learning
is actually happening.
So we are trying to take
the data that we had
and parse through it and figure
out what we can do with it.
So just so you know, this
data is from three statistics
courses from 2013
to 2017, taught
multiple times, 11 total
exams, about 900 students
in five different cohorts.
And when we had
the second stage,
they were randomized into
225 groups of four to five.
So there's quite a bit
of data to work with.
And the question that we kept
sort of hitting up against
is, what metrics do we use
to try to evaluate this data
and see what it can tell us?
So here are the ones
we came up with.
If you imagine, let's say,
just three people in a group,
instead of four to five, and in
stage 1, this is how they did.
There were three
questions, let's say.
They each got this grade.
Afterwards, they were randomized
into the stage 2 group,
and they did the same subset
of three questions and got 25.
So on one hand, we
have the stage 2 grade
to compare things to.
We could also just take the
average of each of the three
and compare that to
their stage 2 grade.
Sure, straightforward.
We could also say, well, what
about the highest performing
student?
How did the group do relative
to that high performing student?
I'm going to call that
the top student grade,
so that's 25 here.
And then there is this
third one, or fourth one,
I guess, that we thought was
an interesting thing to do,
which is to say, take the best
grade that any student did
on any question.
So for question 1, the
first student did the best.
They got nine, whereas the
other two got eight and seven.
And the second one, the second
student did it the best.
And the third one, the third
So what we have here
is a synthetic--
what we call a super student.
The super student is as
well as anyone in the group
could do on a single one of
the questions pooled together.
So if we look at these four
metrics that we came up with,
the stage 1 averages just the
average student performance
in the group.
The stage 2 is the
collective performance
of the group after
collaboration--
what they were able
to do together.
The top student is the
highest student performance
in the group.
And the super student is
the collective performance
before collaboration.
And one way to think of this
is sort of the raw knowledge
that the group had
before they even
interacted with each
other is the most that all
the people in the group knew
about each question, pooled
together, and then they tried
to go into stage 2 together.
So these are the
four metrics we used.
I'm going to show you results
standardized around the stage 1
result. So here is the
distribution of stage
1 groups centered around zero.
That's the stage
1 group average,
just to give you a
sense of the spread.
In the stage 2, they
did quite a bit better.
In fact, they did about one
standard deviation better
in a group, in group 2, than
they did in the first group 1.
Now, I'm not trying to make
causal claims that we improved
learning by one
standard deviation,
because they did have extra
time to work and all of that.
But it is worth noting that
this one standard deviation
change is a huge change.
We're usually excited in
educational interventions
if we can get 0.2, 0.3
standard deviation increases,
and here we have 1.
If we compare that
to the top student,
it's actually quite similar.
So the top student distribution
is also about one standard
deviation better.
And the super student,
the distribution
is like this, which is about
1 and 1/2 standard deviations.
So the super student,
the maybe maximum amount
of knowledge before
collaboration in the group,
is 1 and 1/2 standard deviations
over the stage 1 average.
So here is the metric that I
think is quite interesting.
If we take these two
gains and figure out
what percentage of
the super student
was reclaimed by
the stage 2 group,
we get this measure of the
extent to which the group was
able to sort of harvest the
knowledge from one another
and contribute it to
their stage 2 group.
So the 66% number we're calling
collaborative efficiency.
This is in contrast to a
term used in psychology
called collaborative
inhibition, which
is how much knowledge is lost
when people work together.
But we're trying to
be positive, so we
did collaborative efficiency.
And the question
is, how efficient
did these groups work?
How much were they able to
reclaim the maximum amount
of knowledge that was pooled
across them before they
interacted?
And here's what the
distribution looks like.
So a 1 means 100% efficiency,
means that the stage 2
group did as well as
the collective knowledge
going into it.
So they were able
to reclaim 100%
of the knowledge in the group.
What's kind of
interesting about this
is that there are people
in which, as a group,
they did collectively better
than the pooled amount
of knowledge in the group.
So that's at least
evidence for the suggestion
that collaborating
actually helped
to generate knowledge,
not just kind of spread
the knowledge around in
a way that was useful.
So the thing about
collaborative efficiency
that I think is really worth
doing is that, in the Kennedy
School, and I think in a
lot of professional schools,
a thing we actually want to
stimulate in our students
is the ability to reclaim this
information in a group context.
Usually in the
Kennedy School, we
say, well, if you work in a
group, that's negotiations.
If you're trying to lead a
group, that's leadership.
But we teach quantitative
classes, Dan and I,
in the Kennedy
School, and we want
people to be able to
collaborate and interact
on quantitative questions
just as much as they do when
trying to negotiate something.
And so that's a skill that
I want to actually develop--
articulating the reason
why you have that position,
understanding the position
of your other group members,
and being able to assess the
strengths and shortcomings
of your colleagues'
positions, and then
trying to convince
them otherwise.
Knowing when you're
wrong, understanding
why they might be
right or wrong,
trying to communicate that--
that's a crucial skill
that we hope that graduates of
the Kennedy School will have.
And that's something
that I think
we're getting toward measuring
using this two-stage exam.
So reaching this collective
position led to these lessons
that I want to talk about, which
is, trying to improve learning,
just experimenting with ways
to make learning better,
has led us to find a way to
measure a skill that I didn't
even sort of realize
I really cared about,
and I didn't even
sort of realized
that I was trying very hard
to generate with my students.
And the experience
has led me to think--
we do a lot of active
learning in our classes,
we do group work, we
do things like that.
But I had sort of
treated that as a means
to get more knowledge,
not necessarily
as an end in and of itself.
And I'm starting
to think maybe this
is the thing that I actually
want to foster in my students,
develop, and maybe
even evaluate--
evaluate the extent to which
they're able to collaborate.
And so that has been our sort
of process with two-stage exams.
We've gotten to this new
measure, and in the process,
it's had quite a
bit of an effect
on how I approach teaching.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]